[Music]
we all have our favorite cartoon
characters but do you know who plays
Bugs Bunny Ash Ketchum Eric Cartman Bart
Simpson and several others you'd be
surprised when you hear just how many of
them play multiple characters on your
favorite show if you're new here hit
that subscribe button to never miss
another video and don't forget to give
us a big thumbs up let's check out the
voices behind your favorite cartoons
Veronica Taylor and Sarah nada Kenny as
Ash Ketchum we bet there's a lot of you
who have seen at least one Pokemon
episode whether it's the newer one with
improved graphics or the original but do
you know the voices behind it one
perhaps least known facts is the voice
of Ash Ketchum actually belongs to a
woman Sarah NAT Oh Kenny voiced Ash in
the Pokemon TV series which ran all the
way from 2005 to 2007 Teen Veronica
Taylor on the other hand gave ash his
voice since 1997 and all the way until
2005 pretty impressive right you might
also know Veronica as the voice of Ash's
mom she's also the voice of April O'Neil
on Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles which
means she had a chance to work in some
of the most kick-ass cartoons ever you
can actually meet Veronica if you go to
huge comic-con events as she is known to
regularly attend them and has no issues
posing with her fans and giving out
autographs and in case you were
wondering veronica was just as addicted
to the Pokemon Go app as many of us
meanwhile Sarah is definitely the one
that has been voicing Ash the longest
one of her favorite Pokemon episodes is
lights camera pika and she says the
coolest thing is she's able to see
Pokemon fans grow up have kids and make
their kids fall in love with Pokemon to
Trey Parker as Eric Cartman Trey Parker
is the voice of one of the most
critically acclaimed cartoons and one of
the most beloved characters ever Eric
Cartman is the character you just can't
help but love even though you sometimes
would really wish he'd be less annoying
Trey Parker the man behind Cartman's
voice was also featured in Despicable Me
3 where he plays Balthasar brats but
most people don't know everything this
man did for South Park apart from
playing Cartman in every single episode
Trey was also part of South Park's music
department he composed the music for 201
South Park episode and
lyrics to 222 episodes looks like his
major in music definitely paid off it
might be a little less known fact is
that Trey's actually the co-creator of
the show he created 287 episodes and
wrote a whopping 270 yep looks like Eric
Cartman is actually the brains of the
whole South Park operation Trey also
admitted that he thought one of the
episodes was so bad he begged other
creators not to let him go ahead with it
he said the episode will ruin the show's
legacy and he couldn't even sleep the
night of aired it was the make love not
war craft episode which turned out to be
one of the most beloved episodes ever
Harley word as Peppa Pig but let's talk
about a show that's popular with all of
your youngsters out there it's safe to
say that peppa pig is the most popular
and probably most successful pig ever
the show has been on air since 2009 and
through the years Harley's voice was
heard by millions of kids
Harley bird is an adorable redhead who
was just five years old when she landed
her first big television role yep it was
the role of Peppa Pig this youngster
gave voice to the popular Peppa for
seven years and practically grew up with
the show she's also the youngest winner
of the best performer award which is
pretty cool when she's not lending her
voice to the famous kappa harley can be
found in a kickboxing class and in 2015
she reported that she was just a few
months away from getting a black belt
Harley also voiced papa in Peppa Pig the
golden boots movie and she also briefly
appeared in a doctor who's in the
forests of the night episode as Ruby for
someone who started out active at the
age of five Harley definitely has a
bright future ahead of her we're all
excited to see new Peppa Pig episodes
and so is Harley who says she wants to
play Peppa and tell she's a grandma Bill
Fagor back as Patrick Starr if you've
watched our previous video on the voices
behind your favorite cartoons you
already know all about the man behind
Sponge Bob but today it's all about our
favorite character from the show Patrick
Starr is someone you can't help but love
even though his stupidity can sometimes
make you incredibly frustrated Patrick
is played by the brilliant Bill saeger
back who's been voicing the character
ever since 1999 he might also know Bill
as Marvin on How I Met Your Mother and
Alan Parrish on Jumanji the TV series
but the
and behinds Patrick is actually pretty
busy and has an impressive acting career
he played Harry on dumb and dumber the
TV series and he even had cameos on
shows like Sabrina the Teenage Witch and
Jackie Chan adventures bill was actually
a football star in college but quit the
sport for theater after her friend
suggested they should sign up
it sounds strangely like the plot of
High School Musical does next bill also
thinks football for the immersion into
teamwork and focus which he says is
easily translatable into any kind of
acting work he's doing he said that
Patrick's character changed over the
years and became much more layered and
complicated as the show progressed it
seems totally incredible that a
footballer completely changed his
passion and became an iconic voice of
her artists doesn't it Christine
Kavanagh as dexter from dexters
laboratory yep you heard it right Dexter
was actually played by a talented woman
Christine Kavanagh gave her voice to
Dexter from the moment the show first
aired in 1996 to the very last scene in
2003 you might also know her from
playing Chuckie Finster in Rugrats and
bathed the pig from the same named movie
unfortunately Christine passed away in
2014 at the age of 51 but not before she
was able to light up the cartoon world
with her amazing sense of humor by
bringing more than a dozen cartoon
characters to life her voice also made
random appearances in the Powerpuff
Girls and 101 Dalmatians the series as
well as Sonic the Hedgehog where she
played the bunny rabbits the best fun
fact of our Christine's career is that
she was best known for voicing male
characters that's right very few of the
ones we've mentioned were actually
females in 2000 Christine said she gets
a certain freedom from voice acting
she'd never be able to get by playing
the same on screen because she's able to
become a grandma a baby or even an
animal without needing any special
visuals her acting career was pretty
short as she completely stopped working
in 2001 and moved back home to be closer
to her family she passed away 13 years
later but the cause of her death is yet
unknown
Wayne Alwine as Mickey Mouse born in
1947 Wayne has had a special
relationship with Mickey Mouse since
1977 when he first brought the character
to life in the famous Mickey Mouse Club
and continued giving the voice to the
famous Mouse and tell his
in the year 2009 if you look at his
acting resume you'll see that most if
not all of his roles include only Mickey
Mouse he really gave life to this iconic
character but his Mickey Mouse story is
much more interesting than that we all
know Mickey Mouse and Minnie Mouse were
together but did you know that the
real-life Mickey and Minnie Mouse were
also a couple the actors Wayne all wine
and Russi Taylor weren't only married
characters they were also married in
real life pretty cool right and even
though Wayne Alwine passed away in 2009
his legacy as Mickey Mouse lives on and
there will be no other actor that could
possibly in capture the same Mickey
Mouse spirit although his acting career
was truly dedicated to Mickey Mouse
Wayne had a chance to work in the sound
Department of some of the most
interesting movies he got a chance to
produce sound effects for movies such as
starch at five the final frontier in her
space and even three men and a baby
pretty impressive for a cartoon mouse
right Seth MacFarlane as Peter Griffin
we've mentioned South Park so we
absolutely have to talk about the man
South Park seems to hate Seth MacFarlane
is the creator of Family Guy and the
voice behind one of the most iconic
cartoon dads ever Peter Griffin much
like Homer Simpson and other cartoon
dads he's also a character you just
can't help but love even though he can
get pretty frustrating at times
Seth was also the creator of American
Dad Ted the movie and he even wrote
episodes for cartoon shows like cow and
chicken
Johnny Bravo Dexter's Laboratory and
even Ace Ventura pet detective with his
unique sense of humor and an incredible
skill for writing some of the funniest
scenes ever we're sure Seth will be able
to come up with even more shows that
will make us laugh for years to come
Family Guy frequently jokes about shows
like The Simpsons and South Park and
although they have been able to bury the
hatchet with The Simpsons South Park
fans seem to have it in for Seth and his
team it's a constant feud between the
two fandoms as the show's also rival for
best cartoons of all time
we can't pick our favourite but if you
can make sure to let us know in the
comments below
do you prefer South Park or Family Guy
Alex Hirsch as grunkle Stan everyone
knows Alex Hirsch as the creator of
gravity falls but did you know just how
many voices he plays in the show Alex
plays both grunkle Stan and the iconic
zoos and both characters always manage
to make us laugh especially when they're
together but
as an actor Alex even appeared in Rick
and Morty as Toby Matthews and fish
hooks as clementa but Alex Hirsch is
best known for creating a series that
had all of us hooked made us wait during
the hiatus and then broke our hearts
when we found out the shows actually
over apart from playing grunkle Stan and
creating one of the best cartoons ever
Alex is also known as having some of the
most daring sense of humor just check
his Twitter account he always jokes
about making new gravity fall series and
talks about the episodes he never got a
chance to do he also frequently engages
with the Illuminati Twitter accounts
which only adds more to the gravity
falls controversy did you know that Alex
appeared on The Late Show with David
Letterman because he won a bird calling
contest in his high school but ever
since he was little his true passion was
to make cartoons we can't wait to see
what's in store for Alex in the next few
years and we're still keeping our
fingers crossed for new gravity falls
episode peter robbins as charlie brown
peter was just a child after when he
first landed his Charlie Brown role in
peanuts born in 1956 Peter was one of
the very few that was able to put on the
cute voice needed to make Charlie Brown
come to life he became one of the most
iconic voiceover actors ever who
dedicated his career to the Charlie
Brown role even though he also made
small cameos and plenty of movies and
even portrayed Alexander Bumstead in the
TV series blondie but unlike other
actors Peter spate isn't as bright or
memorable his last professional acting
credit was listed in 1972 since then
Peter has been in trouble with the law
and was afforded to act out on his
lawyer as well as the judge during one
of his trials for stalking charges in
2013 in 2015 he was sentenced to five
years in prison after making criminal
threats during his first probation
sentence and has been reported to have
several outbursts in court but even
though the troubled actor definitely
seemed to have left his cartoon career
in the past we think Charlie Brown would
definitely not be the same without Peter
Robbins and we truly hope he'll be able
to learn his lessons and revive his role
as one of the cutest cartoon characters
ever a Nancy Cartwright
as Bart Simpson perhaps one of the most
surprising discoveries ever was when
everyone found out Bart Simpson is
actually voiced by an iconic woman that
also plays Nelson bulks Ralph Wiggum
and several other characters on The
Simpsons it all started back in 1987
when Nancy auditioned for the role of
Lisa Simpson she read her monologue but
what stood out about her was the
character she didn't even know existed
she immediately connected with Bart a
ten-year old school hating underachiever
and the rest is history it was a
last-minute decision that changed her
life forever
it's hard to believe that this woman
gives her voice to seven Simpsons
characters in total you can hardly tell
just by listening to them talk because
she can effortlessly switch from one
character to another in no time
she calls it vocal gymnastics and it's
exactly what makes her such an iconic
voice of her artists Nancy also played
Rufus in Kim Possible Chuckie Finster
and Rugrats and gave her voice to more
than a dozen other cartoon characters
she says she's living her dream and
voice acting was something she wanted to
do since she was 16 so next time you
watch The Simpsons pay attention if you
can spot Nancy Cartwright some vocal
gymnastics when you listen to Bart
Maggie Nelson Ralph Kearney Todd and
Database that's it for our video don't
forget to subscribe to our Channel and
hit that like button for more videos
like this one see you next time
[Music]